my wife and i talked about some of the
things this week and uh about records
and so forth and uh not and i told her i
said listen
if a human did it before a human can do
it again yeah i just don't know when i'm
gonna see it but i hear me can do it yo
i i hear you but i i don't want you to
diminish what you did because it's like
it's very diminishing all right good i'm
not admitted because i know guys like me
and him are just like not only are you
talented but the talent and durability
together yeah i mean it drove me crazy
as a young kid watching you you made me
cry once you know we lost my shoulder i
like him better now my shoulders hurt
and he just kept running for 20 yard
gains in the in week 16 for home field
advantage up in new york on the
astroturf which is still i think one of
your greatest interests ever greatest i
can honestly say i did not try to make
you cry okay you didn't i wasn't doing
it on purpose okay i was definitely
johnny yeah i know you were do you want
to to live to see someone break that
record or or are you hoping that even
though it's inevitable do you hope it
lasts as long as possible you know the
one thing i have
come to learn that records are made to
be broken
and i would love to live to see it
happen
i would love to be there and be in my
right mind uh to be able to shake that
person's hand and to be able to to
celebrate with him
uh because that's what i would have
wanted to do with walter page and i did
not have that chance to do it with
peyton i did it with his family right
but to have would have having him near
would have been
awesome uh because he and i had a
conversation about his record in years
prior
but
that to me would have been
been been the icing on the cake is there
anybody here in recent history since you
retired that you got like you know a
little like a little nervous with or
you're like oh this guy like has anybody
like adrian peterson adrian peterson and
not frank gore frank gordon's gonna run
till the 50s
but still adrian peterson was the one
guy uh that i thought was the most
recent active player that i thought
would have a chance to get in there
right yeah um and he still does i mean
he's not done no he's not done yet
frank
if people keep signing him he will play
till he's 50. yeah and he looks like he
still could yeah no um all right so
here's another thing that just jumps out
to me jimmy johnson right just get into
the hall of fame
realistically when you think about that
like how many super bowls you think you
guys would have won
or what would have been different if
jimmy johnson had stayed you know
that's a very good question it's a very
fair question and and my answer is is
pretty simple i think we were blessed to
win the number of super bowls that god
wanted us to win
now
could we have one more i don't know
what jimmy would have done he probably
ran us into the ground because he was a
hard-nosed coach he wanted things a
certain way he was going to beat us up
in practice right and the question would
have been how long can we maintain
that level of intensity that level of
of physicality
yeah right and so maybe that would have
shortened my career where i would have
never gotten all the time becoming
all-time leading rusher i don't know
but and that's why i sit here and say
well we got what we deserve right and
you get what you deserve right now that
all went down in the days before cell
phones and text messages but you know it
was march or april of of 94 and all of a
sudden jimmy johnson's out as the head
coach what kind of reaction was there
among your teammates when this
relationship falls apart and jimmy's
gone total disbelief
total shock
and
the residue of y
still remains yeah that's why we're
having this conversation you're right
you're right residue of why still
remains there's no clear-cut answer no
no no answers been given to the real why
it's the unknown why but if you talk to
jimmy jimmy will tell you like this
he was getting tired
he was planning on doing it
either that year or prior to he was
planning on doing that right because he
wanted to give back to miami get on his
boat yeah he was
moving to that level of
qtl as he would say quality time left i
think
the year prior to that he may have lost
his mom
somewhere up in that range
and it kind of gave him this revelation
of the time that he's putting into the
game
and the time that he's losing from his
family right as you would know yeah
definitely and so there's a lot of time
that we put into this game and and
that's selfish time
it is selfish time for for a reason
because you're this is your job
and this is what is required of you yeah
and when that you put in that kind of
those kind of hours someone else is
losing
a son a daughter right a wife a family
and for jimmy to come to the realization
like hey
i don't have enough i'm tired of being
the bad guy i want to get back to the
keys get on my boat and do the things
that i want to do to enjoy life and i
can respect that
you um
my dad always says the 92 cowboy team is
the best team he ever played right and
they played some good ones i'm
interested who's the best team
emma smith ever played like who's the
one team that you played where you're
like damn that might be the
the best team where i mean is it the
49ers teams you were doing it out with
or was somebody later on after your run
that that jumps out to you
it was the baltimore ravens that defense
that we had ran up against against the
ravens right was one of the best
defenses i've ever played the 99 ravens
yes lord they were they were they were
solid now we weren't that good right but
they were that good they were that good
they were that good that that that's the
one that jumps out oh yeah yeah best
defense you ever played now their
offense wasn't worth a damn but you that
that defense that didn't defense was
their offense right it was it was this
is unbelievable you know i was on the
field with emin in his last game ever
i could have ruined his last game ever
that's one of my great achievements how
i had a audible that gruden told me if
they play this defense right you guys
had uh you know who was the big safety
adrian
right right he's coming down we had this
audible ready and we called it up to a
florida running back graham uh uh ernest
ernest graham yeah the man and he's open
down the sideline i got a little
pressure i got to throw it a little
early and i missed him and we're going
to win the game i'm going to send
emmett's career off on a bad note and i
missed the damn throw and i just i'm
shocked i'm shocked by that outcome i'm
shocked
i'm shocked
you let emmett walk into retirement have
a little tequila tell us about that
bottle you won't like well
hetadora and i've been working together
for the last nine to ten years and so
they're celebrating 150 year anniversary
this year
in distilling the finest tequila on the
planet
this right here what we have in front of
us is the hedador ultra which is a inejo
you normally don't see any hoes that i
was gonna say because i like tequila
yeah you normally don't see any hoes
this color this is like a silver blanco
color right so they do a number of
different techniques and this right here
is
real real smooth this is a premium
tequila and it is
i'll put this up against any of them it
looks that's a cool bottle and uh i
could tell you that i will be drinking
some of this as a friday night for sure
i like this right wait until friday why
wait through four well because i got to
get up early and talk to you tomorrow
morning we're having it tomorrow morning
get a bloody mary yeah
drop some of that a little more drop a
little bit of that in there we're having
the annual pft dinner tonight you're
gonna have a little tequila tonight
i'll get a bottle here
tonight where's the dinner
at las fuegos you're invited okay i'm
invited lost legos
no not everybody no not everybody
i'm talking to my people
6 30 be there
all right evan hey man great seeing as
always
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports